And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call, we have just a few questions today.
So if you have any questions as you can think of, and we have a pretty small group, I understand
it's right before Thanksgiving.
So if you have any questions, feel free to think of them in chat or we're going to have a fairly
short call.
It's okay sometimes too.
So let's get started.
A reminder to those that are going to be listed afterwards.
To look at the announcements on the member site, use the member site.
So there's a lot of information on that as well.
All right, let's get to our questions.
How many times can I run a program from the list?
So I assume this person's talking about a rife machine.
How many times can they run a program on the rife machine?
There really, there's not a maximum.
You could run it or you could literally stack a program and run it 24 or 7 if you wanted to.
So, so there's, there's no, there's no number that I could get here.
You could run any program you want as often as you want.
You, you can't hurt yourself with the rife machine and the only,
the only caveat to that is using kill programs when you have Lyme disease.
So if you have Lyme disease and you run into many kill programs,
you could produce too many endotoxins and you could make yourself sick.
And they're making yourself, you know, have a hurt side of a reaction.
But other than that, you can, you can run as often as you want.
Next question.
I wonder if you have thoughts about grounding sheets or grounding pads to reduce inflammation.
If so, is there a brand or product that you'd recommend?
Growning sheets and grounding pads, yes, can be used.
We currently are out of grounding pads and I don't know that we'll get them back in.
We might have a few left if you call me again next week.
We'll see.
Growning sheets, we have a lot left and we're actually having a,
pretty sure Dustin's having a huge sale this weekend, black Friday.
So do look at your email, see if you're going to email on Thursday or Friday
with a discount off the grounding sheets.
Now you could use a grounding sheet for a pad too.
I mean, you could keep it folded up and sit on it and your chair and then plug it into the ground.
So the grounding sheets are more versatile that way.
Maybe they're not as stylish as the foam type grounding pad.
That the grounding sheets are larger and they can be used for more things.
And then tie that into the question from the chat.
Would it be okay to use a grounded pad with the right machine?
If you're going to use a grounded pad or a grounding sheet with the right machine,
I suggest you use it on just the lower half of your body.
So those that are using the right machine at night,
I always recommend that you only use the grounding sheet.
You put the grounding sheet on the lower half of your bed.
Because you don't want the frequencies to get drawn through the ground.
So when you have something connected to a ground,
it's going to attract frequencies.
So we don't want to lose them and not have them go through your body.
Now, again, it's depends on how you use it.
Let's say you sleep only on your back.
And you have a grounding sheet under the fitted sheet.
So you're laying on top of a grounding sheet and you put the bulb on your belly
and it stays on your belly all night long.
Well then, so you're radically,
then the frequencies are going through you with it to the ground.
So you're still getting all those frequencies.
But that's not real.
I mean, most people are rolling around the bulb slaying next to them part of the night.
It's not always on their belly.
So therefore I tell people to put the grounding sheets on the lower half of the bed.
That's better operation.
Now this person who asked this question,
I'm going to read the question.
I did not include their first part of their question because quite honestly,
it wasn't, it wasn't understandable.
So I just would ask that they just try to take more care and formulating their question.
So I can understand what you're asking.
They said this in through the member site.
Which, okay, let me just answer the question.
I have been doing B17,
which I am increasing to two IVs next week.
So this person is doing B17 IVs, I believe.
This person is not doing really any nutritional protocol from me.
So they are doing that.
I believe they're using the right.
I'm not even positive about that.
I haven't heard much from this person.
I'm all, I also am highly contemplated using the starting the Fendezon Ivermectin.
So just looking for advice.
I have some Ivermectin but my source went out of business.
So I would need to do source and I'm not sure where to get Fendezon.
Okay, so if you have access to the member site,
which you do the whole protocol for Fendezon Ivermectin is right on the first page of the member site,
including a link to purchase the Fendezon.
We sell the Fendezon.
The Ivermectin I can't legally give you information and where to buy it.
So you'll let to find your source of Ivermectin.
I can't help you with that.
But the Fendezon is legal to purchase.
We sell that on our store and then as far as advice for that,
you can certainly make an appointment with me so we can have a call.
But I don't know that you need to
because all the entire protocol for Fendezon Ivermectin is on the member site.
And then we've had this question come up probably 50 times.
So I probably have at least 20 videos on this as well.
So make sure you look at that as well.
I understand the difficulty with using Ivermectin is trying to find a source
where you're going to be able to get the right dosage.
And that's always a little bit of a struggle.
But I think that we have enough people that are on Ivermectin
that they haven't had a problem.
Find eat it.
Now remember your dose of Ivermectin,
you have to convert your body weight from pounds to kilograms.
And the dose for Ivermectin for cancer is one half milligram per kilogram of body weight.
So let's say you weight 50 kilograms per tenth.
So your dose would be 25 kilograms of Ivermectin per day.
That would be your starting dose.
And then depending on how bad your cancer is and how fast it's progressing,
you move up in your dose of Ivermectin from one half milligram per kilogram
to one milligram per kilogram.
And we have some people taking two milligrams per kilogram.
Fendezon is a little bit different.
The recommendation for fendezon is all over the place.
I know Dr. Mackis recommends fairly high dose fendezon
because he's mainly dealing with people that are late, late, late stage cancer.
And he's trying to hit it really hard quickly.
The Joe Tippen's original fendezon protocol only called for 22 milligrams
three days a week, four days off.
But literally the protocol is people are doing all sorts of different things
with fendezon.
Some people are taking that original dose of 222 milligrams just daily.
Some people are taking four times that much daily.
Some people are taking two packets of fendezon also,
44 milligrams, four days a week or three days a week and then three days off.
There's benefits to pulsing it on and off like three days on,
four days off or four days on three days off or something like that
because fendezon has a tendency to do some damage to the liver.
So you do need to keep an eye on your liver markers,
your alkaline phosphates, your AST and ALT.
You do need to keep an eye on those because about 50% of the people
end up having liver disruption from fendezon.
We haven't really seen that with Ivermactin, but fendezon
is the nasty one under your liver.
Good. A kidney stone occurrence after my last blood work
be the cause of higher PSA and stubborn inflammation
and other bad blood, blood work markers.
So if you had, if you didn't have any pain from,
let's say you didn't have any pain, no issues,
no knowledge of a kidney stone and then you go get your blood tested.
And then you find out afterwards.
So you go get your blood drawn that you find out three days later
that you have a kidney stone and you have all sorts of symptoms
because of that.
Then I would say no.
But if you were in the middle of a kidney stone passing
and it was a lot of pain,
that would cause a lot of inflammation.
And yes, that could throw off your blood work.
It could even throw off your PSA.
But if you weren't having those symptoms
at the time of the blood draw,
then I would say probably not
because a kidney stone that isn't giving you symptoms
is not going to really do really a disruption.
The fact that the kidney stone is in the kidneys,
let's say it's not causing any issues.
Could a kidney stone or the kidney's cause
abnormal blood markers?
Maybe with kidney markers?
Maybe your BUN?
Yes, but as far as elevating the PSA, I doubt that.
If you again, if you were the throws of passing
a kidney stone with an enormous amount of pain,
that could throw off a lot of things
because inflammation is going to be so high.
But you probably wouldn't have a lot of,
you might have difficulty in blood markers
showing stress on the kidney if you had
an asymptomatic kidney stone.
But it probably would not be raised
any other markers other than this kidney markers
if it was an asymptomatic.
If you were at an asymptomatic stage,
hopefully that helps that.
I mean, using the right for two months now,
why am I not better yet?
This was a question from somebody who asked me
thoroughly, and I put it on here because they also asked
if about their supplements.
They've only been taking their supplements
for a few months as well.
I don't think it's unfair to yourself
to have unrealistic expectations.
Can a person have miraculous results
in even two weeks of using the right?
Yes, because we've seen it.
We've actually seen people after just a few days of using
the right having miraculous results.
I mean, their symptoms gone away.
But you have to be a realist too.
So a lot of people are very optimistic.
A lot of people are very pessimistic.
I tend to be very realistic.
So I don't want to be pie in the sky
giving hope that is unwarranted.
We've seen literal miracles with the right,
but sometimes it takes a long time.
With my own cancer, it took me a year and a half
to really see a difference in my cancer,
even though I was using the right on a daily basis,
even all night and during the day at work.
So it took a long time for things to change.
Also, you've got to look at, you know,
most people, you know, the old saying,
Rome wasn't built in the day.
You didn't get cancer overnight,
even though you think I was healthier than an ox.
My whole life and also I have cancer.
What is the cost?
Now, we can't have, and we've seen post-COVID vaccine,
people with very rapidly progressing cancers.
But for the most part,
a cancer's been growing in a person's body
for a number of years before it gets to the point
where you end up with a diagnosis.
So you have to give yourself some time for your body to heal,
and you have to be willing to make the changes.
So if you're not willing to make lifestyle changes,
if you're not staying at the top of taking your supplements,
if you're not taking your life,
I had somebody ask a question,
was it about a year ago,
they're upset that they were getting sick,
and I asked them,
are they using the right?
I tell you, I've had this same answer,
at least a dozen times or more throughout my career.
How you've been doing,
I see you haven't even purchased any supplements,
are you getting them somewhere else?
That's fine with me,
but are you taking them?
No, I haven't been taking them.
I haven't been feeling good.
I haven't been taking them.
Okay, how are you doing with using the right?
Well, I haven't really been using it lately.
Then I get the right back,
and I can tell when I look at it,
and I go into some settings on your computer,
how often everybody's been actually using the right,
who when I see that they haven't used their right for seven months,
it's sad,
or we have a patient that passes away,
and their spouse sends their right back to us,
and donates it to give it to somebody that is less fortunate,
and that's a very nice thing,
but when we get that right back,
and I see they haven't used it for a year,
it just makes me sad.
If you're not doing the things that you've committed to doing,
and we ask everybody before they start with us,
make sure you pray about this is what you're supposed to do.
If you pray about what this is,
this is what you're supposed to do,
then if you're committing to doing it,
and you're paying us money for a piece of equipment,
by all means,
I really want you to be using it.
I don't want people to,
I mean, it's a sad thing when we buy a treadmill,
and it functions as a clothes hanger,
in the corner of our bedroom.
But this is the right machine that can save your life,
so don't stop doing it.
Continue to do the right things.
Your faith can't be in the right machine,
nor can it be in your diet,
nor can it be in your positive mental energy.
Your faith has to be in Jesus Christ,
and He's the one who's going to ultimately bring
to conclusion the conclusion that He desires,
but if we're not doing our part,
then chamber us.
So we need to be doing our part,
doing the right thing,
and continuing with what God has set our feet to
in order for us to expect any results whatsoever.
So it takes time.
We've had people start out on a nutritional protocol,
and then they quit after two months,
and say, well, this is a work I'm going to change
is something else.
Like, you believe it's taking these for two months?
You know, what are you expecting?
And so we have to be realists that things take time.
And you have to be committed to things,
committed to doing the right things.
I'm not saying that we don't tweak things
and change things,
and protocols change,
and nutrition changes,
but you have to stick to it then.
Okay, next question coming in from the chat.
Teenage son has been consulting with you for as active.
He did the Syrex tests,
and is off of gluten, dairy,
sorghum,
sesame, and buckwheat.
He likes the high protein organic yogurt made
from coconut and cashew.
It has a gar in it.
He looked up that ingredient
and wondered what your thoughts on that.
I think that is fine.
That is a thickening agent,
I think.
So, I'm sure you're fine on that.
Also, this brings up another point.
So, if you did the Syrex tests
and you're off of certain foods,
because, you have to say,
because of what test.
So, if you're off of a certain food
because of the Syrex 10,
Syrex array 10.
That Syrex array 10 tests for antibodies in foods.
If you have antibodies in certain foods,
remember, many of those will dissipate.
Gluten probably won't dissipate.
But some of these other ones
like sorghum,
and sesame and buckwheat,
they may, those antibodies may be gone.
He may be able to introduce those foods back into his diet.
Probably not gluten and dairy,
because I know what his issues are.
But the sorghum,
sesame and buckwheat possibly.
So, also consider that.
If you're staying off of the food,
because it's across reacted to a self antibody,
an auto antibody,
that's what it's called.
That means it antibody to your own tissue.
Explain that.
Oh, so let's say if I have antibodies
to my myelin,
she sells in my brain.
And gluten is across reacted,
because it is.
Then you can't eat gluten,
no matter what.
So, it's not because you have gluten antibodies,
it's not because,
you're not staying off of it,
because you have antibodies to gluten,
you're staying off of it,
because gluten is across reacted
in a molecular mimic,
to the myelin,
she sells,
and you have antibodies to myelin,
she sells.
So, every time you have eat gluten,
you're attacking your myelin,
she sells,
you're causing myelin,
she's destruction,
your precipitated,
multiple myelosis,
multiple sclerosis.
So, you don't,
that's a different reason
to stay off food.
So, no, it's because
of the food antibody test,
well, then some of those things
could be reintroduced
as those antibodies
dissipate.
No, I'm staying off it
because I have,
because you said it's a molecular mimic
to the thyroid,
which gluten is a molecular mimic
to the thyroid.
So, anybody that has thyroid issues,
hypothyroidism,
or and-or-hashimodo
should not be gluten.
So, you don't eat it,
not because you have antibodies
to gluten,
which you may or may not have,
but you're not eating it
because you have,
it's a molecular mimic
to the thyroid,
or whatever tissue
we're talking about.
I don't,
that wasn't your question,
but I think a guard
is just fine.
Next question,
should I be taking any additional
vitamins like C,
D, and zinc
in addition to
your supplements?
So, no.
No.
I'm-
the protocol,
I put you a-
you have the D in it,
and zinc is in it,
and you don't want extra
vitamin C.
So, remember,
vitamin C,
say you're going to take
a thousand milligrams
of vitamin C,
I think that really is good
because it helps me
keep away from colds.
That's antioxidant,
we don't want antioxidants
in that dose
in what we're dealing
with cancer.
So, no, no,
no vitamin C.
You are taking D,
it's in your immune pack,
and zinc is in your immune pack.
So, you're covered.
Next question,
skin problems
think zinc 50 milligrams a day
cleared by skin.
Yeah, zinc can be really good.
It can be good for skin.
I totally agree with that comment.
Thank you for that.
Well, if you enjoyed this late,
I said we only had a few questions
come in.
So, if you have any other questions,
now would be the time
to ask them.
There'll be a shortism
called we've ever had.
Well, sometimes around holidays.
Those are calls I'm kind of short.
I hope everybody has a great
Thanksgiving plan
that you're going to do
something with your family.
Everything's giving to you.
Thank you.
And enjoy the weather here
up here in Minnesota.
We got some snow last night,
which we didn't get hardly
any snow all year long last year.
It was a very sad,
sad winter.
So, we like snow.
Okay, I haven't reviewed the binder section.
How important is that area?
Well, you could look through the binder
and on what area in the binder
you're talking about.
Some people say,
oh, I kind of knew all that stuff
in the binder.
You'll be getting a binder
in the mail.
Don't just don't worry about
the binder online.
You'll be getting a binder
in the mail.
That's a true three-reg binder.
So, if you haven't got that yet,
you can look at that.
If you get that in.
All right.
Well, thank you everybody
for being on tonight.
Have a blessed weekend
and we'll see you all next week.
All right.
Bye-bye.